you raised three hundred and
sixty thousand dollars actually over
three hundred and sixty thousand dollars
uh for something that you came up with
all on your own called covid 19
protest relief fund
i want to talk about this right away
because it's so important and inspiring
tell us what that fund is uh it
it's basically a fund for protesters who
are
out on the front lines fighting uh in
this what i call
the uprising for our justice inequality
and
in the midst of our our pandemic and
putting the
risks in their bodies on the line some
of them being in height
in communities that are already at high
risk and i was like man
there should be some kind of relief for
treatment for some bills for some bail
relief for injuries seeing all of the
attacks that were happening on
protesters just for
just for using their american right to
speak out
uh so i just wanted to do something
because i was i was uh
i was having a bunch of different
conversations with folks and including
my my family who's high risk so i
couldn't be outside when the protests
were happening and i was like
i usually am so i'm like damn i kind of
feel a little useless
in this whole movement i need to do
something and i was like man there's a
lot of bodies out there somebody should
come up with a
like a like a relief fund like somebody
should do that when i said somebody i
meant like the government because it's
like their jobs
uh but you know i guess that was like
wishing too much so then i said that for
like two weeks and then i was like well
why don't you do that just just start a
gofundme yo people do it all the time
i had never done a gofundme before so i
just i just kind of
googled how to go fund me and just went
to the site did it and i was like hoping
that it would maybe catch on and
some other people like that were more
prominent would would do
would do it and make i didn't know what
we would make that much money and um
by the fifth hour we we were like
already over 80
80 000 and i was like oh man
i need to figure out how to give money
to the people because i don't play with
people's money you know so
that became a three-week crash course uh
getting
getting to know organizers across the
country getting no act activists
learning what uh a non-profit versus a
mutual aid fund was which ours is a
mutual aid fund
and and learning how it operates because
my whole thing was getting the money to
the people as soon
as quickly as we could but i guess i had
the best uh i was in the best scenario
where it's like
usually you start a a mutual aid fund or
a not-for-profit and then you like
try to raise money i had all the money
and no knowledge so uh between all the
help and the organizers that really uh
educated me on a lot of on a lot of the
things i needed to know
um i was able to set it up and and um
and get it going and it's been really
cool to uh be on
the other side of it now where the
logistics are kind of worked out and now
we're just
trying to get as much money out to the
people and make us as a big impact as
possible good for you i mean god bless
you that's an amazing thing to do i
would think it would be kind of
i would i could see you being panicked
if 360 thousand dollars comes in
and you want to get it to the people but
there's this period of time where the
money is just pouring in and you think
like how do i get rid of this money
yeah like being on breaking bad like
there's money coming in i gotta get
i gotta get rid of this stuff because i
was like
i was waking up like i gotta get rid of
this because i'm i'm just a comic man
i wanna make dick jokes man there are so
many times
conan that i almost tweeted i bought a
chain with it instead
just just a joke but i was like i can't
do this i can't until i figure out how
to do this i can't i know
i know it's a funny it's a funny joke
but people would get pissed off for a
second
um yeah man uh but yeah it was it was
like a lot of it was like a lot of
stress
because it was it was a world i'm not
i'm not um familiar with but i'm so glad
i did it
and on top of that we've worked with uh
the chicago alliance and
you know the black lives matter chicago
uh and a bunch of other organizations
just
getting matched to people taking care of
tests uh we've been getting so many
cool notes about people like being able
to pay their rent because they're not
behind
these medical bills and and there's a
lot of people just getting beat up man a
lot of people getting beat up a lot of
phones a lot of iphones were broken in
the uprising
uh we've been able to take care of folks
in this and it's been the best
it's been a joy man it's been something
that brings a lot of light to
what's been a stressful time for me
personally for sure as everybody else